this
i have placed information vital to the
survival of the rebellion into the
memory systems of this r2 unit
use the force
spies
saboteurs
assassins
everything i did
i did for the rebellion
[Music]
an imperial pilot
is telling people they're making a
weapon what kind of weapon a planet
killer we call it the death style and
the day is coming
when it will be unleashed
the pilot says he was sent by your
father it appears he is critical to the
development of this super weapon
i've placed a weakness deep within the
system the reactor module that's the
place i've laid my trap
we need to stop this weapon before it is
finished
[Music]
war is inevitable
make 10 men feel like 100.
enemy fighters coming in
the death star plans are down there
we'll find a way to find them here we go
[Music]
[Music]
the empire has been choking us
i found someone i think can help
this wednesday
cassianander
comes the next star wars event how do
you know about me
you won't want a mess
time has come to force their hand
at what cost
everything hang on
star wars and or three episode premiere
streaming wednesday